Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Seven: the rule of law, your rights and duties, punishment, and the police.
Every democracy has to answer one hard question: how far can the state go?
In a democracy like the Danish one, there are limits to the state's power over the individual citizen.
Citizens have a number of fundamental rights which the state must respect, and which protect them against abuse by the power of the state.
The constitution thus protects a number of freedoms and human rights which the state power, including the Folketing, must respect.
The constitution contains, among other things, protection of freedom of expression, ytringsfrihed, which is the right to freely express your opinions and to freely communicate your thoughts to others.
Freedom of assembly, forsamlingsfrihed, the right to freely gather and together express your views.
And freedom of association, foreningsfrihed, the right to form associations and to be a member of these associations.
Freedom of expression, freedom of assembly and freedom of association are all crucial preconditions for a democracy.
They are called the political freedoms.
If democracy is to function, there must be a free and open debate.
People must have the right to criticise, challenge and ask critical questions to those in power, public institutions or religious authorities.
So in Denmark you cannot demand that other people never criticise your religion.
The limits are set by law, for example defamation, and only the courts decide whether they have been crossed.
Everyone must also have the right to meet with others and to be a member of a political association.
Citizens must together be free to develop and mark common views, whether or not they go against the views of the majority.
In Denmark, these basic freedoms are, as mentioned, protected in the constitution.
This means citizens have the right to express themselves, form associations and hold meetings, without the state having to approve this in advance.
The Danish constitution forbids censorship.
That means the government cannot demand that, for example, books and newspapers must be approved before they are published.
Every freedom is exercised under responsibility.
There are therefore certain limits to the political freedoms.
If you for example exceed the limits of the law for freedom of expression, you can, depending on the circumstances, be punished and sentenced to pay compensation.
This applies, among other things, if you speak about other citizens in a way that violates their honour, defamation.
It also applies if the press exceeds the limits of freedom of expression, for example by writing something offensive, defamatory, about a person.
Likewise, after repeated incidents in which the Koran was burned in public, it has also become forbidden to publicly treat certain religious writings improperly by burning or otherwise destroying them.
An association can also be judged unlawful and demanded dissolved if it seeks to reach its goals by violence or other illegality.
But the limits are wide in Denmark.
It is also part of democracy that only the courts can decide whether the limits for freedom of expression and other rights secured by the constitution have been exceeded.
The constitution also limits the state's possibility to interfere in the individual citizen's private life.
The constitution thus protects personal freedom, the inviolability of the home, and the right of property.
The constitution also has some provisions that secure citizens the right to certain benefits from the public sector.
Children have the right to free education in the folkeskole.
And citizens have the right to certain public help, if they meet certain obligations in the law.
The constitution also contains a few rules that forbid discrimination.
It says in the constitution that no distinction can be made between citizens' rights or duties to fulfil ordinary civic duties on the basis of faith or descent.
When rights appear in the constitution, the Folketing and the government must not legislate in conflict with these rights.
But in the last instance it is up to the independent courts to assess whether that happens.
Citizens' fundamental rights are not only protected by the constitution, but also by rules adopted by the Folketing, and by international conventions which Denmark has joined.
In 1992, the European Convention on Human Rights was made part of Danish legislation.
The Convention on Human Rights supplements and builds out the freedoms and human rights that follow from the constitution.
The courts can take a stand on whether Danish authorities comply with the convention's requirements.
Denmark can be convicted at the European Court of Human Rights if the country's laws and decisions conflict with the convention's requirements.
A photo in the chapter shows a demonstration on Christiansborg Palace Square in Copenhagen in 2023 against the abolition of the public holiday Store Bededag.
In 1994, Denmark was convicted at the European Court of Human Rights in a case where a journalist had been sentenced for passing on racist statements.
This happened because he had made a TV item where he interviewed people who made racist statements.
The Court of Human Rights established that the Danish judgment was in conflict with his freedom of expression as a journalist.
Now to the public administration.
The public administration, the state authorities, regions and municipalities, has the task of putting the country's laws into effect.
The public administration must, among other things, make the welfare society's offers available to citizens.
It is also the public administration that collects taxes and duties.
In an international context, the public administration in Denmark is characterised by being very little corrupt.
The public administration must obey the country's laws when it carries out its tasks.
This applies to authorities in the state, regions and municipalities.
The public administration cannot act on its own.
It is said that the administration's actions must have a legal basis, hjemmel, in a law.
The administration must not act in conflict with the laws.
According to the constitution, it is the independent courts that control the public administration.
At the same time, the state must supervise the municipalities.
Citizens can also in certain areas complain to a board if they for example think that their municipality has not complied with the rules of the law.
In the Danish constitution it is also laid down that the administration is controlled by the Parliamentary Ombudsman, Folketingets Ombudsmand.
The Ombudsman assesses whether errors or neglect have occurred in the public authorities' work.
The Ombudsman must help ensure that the public authorities do not do anything illegal, and that they treat citizens in accordance with the applicable legislation and give them the rights they are entitled to.
The Ombudsman is elected by the Folketing, but is independent in their work.
Neither the Folketing, the government nor the public authorities can interfere in the Ombudsman's work.
The Ombudsman cannot overrule a public authority's decision.
But the Ombudsman can criticise and urge the authorities to change practice, and the Ombudsman's written statements therefore still have great importance for the administration's behaviour.
Next: openness, offentlighed.
Openness is often emphasised as one of the most important preconditions of democracy.
The individual citizen must be able to get information about the state and its handling of cases.
The legislative, the judicial and the executive power are all subject to rules about openness.
The Folketing: the meetings are public, so anyone can come and attend the meetings in the chamber.
This is directly in the constitution.
Recordings from the meetings can also be seen on the Folketing's website.
The courts: citizens are allowed to attend all trials.
And the media must be free to inform the population about what happens in trials.
The courts can, however, decide that a trial must be held behind closed doors.
Then neither citizens nor journalists have access to the courtroom.
That can for example be out of consideration for clearing up the case, or for the safety of witnesses, or if the cases concern the security of the state.
The public administration: citizens have, as a starting point, the right to gain insight into the work of the public administration.
It follows from the Public Administration Act, forvaltningsloven, that a party to a case has the right to access to the case's documents, aktindsigt.
Every citizen normally also has the right to know the information which the public administration holds about them.
The Access to Public Administration Files Act, offentlighedsloven, also lays down that anyone, under certain conditions, has the right to see the documents an authority holds.
This applies regardless of whether the documents concern oneself.
But there are some conditions and limits to this right, which after a weighing can mean that other considerations weigh more than the right to access in the specific case.
For example, the right to access normally does not include private information.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which body has as its primary task to check whether there have been neglect or errors in public authorities' handling of cases?
Option A: The Ethics Council.
Option B: The Parliamentary Ombudsman, Folketingets Ombudsmand.
Option C: The Press Council.
[DA] Hvilken instans har som sin primære opgave at kontrollere, om der er sket forsømmelser eller fejl i offentlige myndigheders sagsbehandling?  A: Etisk Råd  |  B: Folketingets Ombudsmand  |  C: Pressenævnet
The answer is B: The Parliamentary Ombudsman, Folketingets Ombudsmand.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in May 2025.
[DA] ✔ B: Folketingets Ombudsmand
Question 2.
According to Danish law, can you demand that another citizen never speaks critically about your religion?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan man ifølge dansk lov kræve, at en anden borger aldrig må udtale sig kritisk om ens religion?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 3.
Which authority can dissolve, ban, an association that seeks to reach its goals by violence?
Option A: The police.
Option B: The courts.
[DA] Hvilken myndighed kan opløse (forbyde) en forening, der søger at opnå sine mål med vold?  A: Politiet  |  B: Domstolene
The answer is B: The courts.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Domstolene
Question 4.
Can a government decide that an association is to be dissolved forever?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan en regering bestemme, at en forening skal opløses for altid?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
That's the end of Part One of Episode 7.
In Part Two, we continue with your duties, punishment, and the police.
See you there.